well i wanted to ask you just
because i do feel like there's uh
when it comes to the armenian community
i i i
want some education on what's going on
right now um
i know there's some sort of there's like
a war going on yeah
i don't know how to pronounce the name
of the other azerbaijan yeah
yeah can you kind of just educate people
what's going on there because i actually
posted something on instagram
which we appreciate i'm
so when i got jack last week the witness
was this little armenian kid
at wing stop and he was like yo they
look like they were armenians so i
posted
two armenian or middle eastern people
right the [ __ ] is god at you and some
guy dm me
respectfully he did only one guy dm me
respectfully though and he was like hey
you should reword that right because
people might think you're
so i did reword it right but i didn't
mean any like malice
and i obviously don't know what's going
on but he's like people might think
you're an agent of whatever that is
say that again azerbaijan yeah right so
it's like a little country uh right
likes to like turkey
we was all part of the soviet union
before but uh the history goes far so
i'll try to say it real quick but if you
heard of the armenian genocide
which is not azerbaijan that's turkey so
turk the modern-day turkey
at the time it was i wanted to get into
that too because i feel like a lot of
people don't understand
it's all kind of interconnected okay
okay um there was armenian genocide in
1915 so
a little more over 100 years ago where a
million and a half armenians were
massacred
by turkey you know what i'm saying the
whole thing about it the reason why we
still protest and still talk about it i
started this whole movement about it
right called open wounds um it's because
to this day it hasn't been recognized as
a genocide so basically they just got
away with killing a 1.5 million people
and history looks the other way and
history looks the other way and you know
if you know that the
the definition of genocide is like the
the planned extermination or the
systematic extermination of a specific
group of people and that's what was
happening like the holocaust of the jews
or whatever you know what i'm saying
so um to this day it hasn't been
recognized so there's always
tension between you know turkey and
armenia and azerbaijan
is like allies with turkey like their
kind of brother and sister country okay
and there's other governments like the
united states that still haven't
recognized either
why because they're allies with turkey
too like
america we got army bases and things
like that because they have this
they have a perfect like entrance into
the middle east
you know i mean as far as like
geographically and america don't want to
lose that
so we need that you know what i'm saying
so it's a lot of political things behind
it obviously
but i mean 48 or 49 individual states
have recognized it mostly i just saw you
countries have right
there a new a new state just recognized
it uh
i think maybe search tanking might have
posted about it oh it could be surge
from system system of it down he's like
super
like he's a real activist he's like into
this yeah like he's like
i kind of system over down's probably my
second favorite band ever
for sure and and i kind of followed in
their footsteps because we grew up on
them and they talked about the armenian
genocide and stuff in
and their music and stuff and then
that's kind of how i started doing that
in hip-hop you know what i'm saying
but uh but yeah so going with all of
that there's always been like a tension
between these countries now in
azerbaijan there's a little piece of
land in the middle of the country
like all of it used to be armenia before
the genocide first of all you know what
i'm saying
then there's a little piece of country
that's like 95 armenian populated
but after the soviet union broke and
everyone became independent the soviet
union decided to give that piece of
country
to azerbaijan instead of even though it
was armenian
that piece of land okay you know what
i'm saying so it's been a war over that
piece of land for like [ __ ] years
decades now
but it's always like coming and going
the main issue now these last few weeks
that it became a big thing because i
guess it was a cease-fire and it's a
middle of a pandemic and all that [ __ ]
but even though there was a cease-fire
they just broke it and they just
attacked not only military
targets but civilian targets like out of
nowhere you know what i'm saying and
that was the whole thing now like yo
what what's happening you know what i'm
saying so that's going on
[ __ ] going on right now yeah right now
damn
you know that that part of the world is
is crazy you know what i'm saying
i was about to ask you like you know i
feel like
especially you know when you think of
like uh
israel and palestine and it's almost
like
is that kind of like if you met someone
who was turkish right
it's like there's automatically just
like it's it's pretty sad because
you know like i said i grew up in
amsterdam if you know anything about
netherlands in europe mad turkish people
it's mad middle eastern people right but
predominantly
in like holland germany france turkish
people i grew up with mad turkish people
i
i turkish i was going to ask you like
yeah that's kind of personally i did
but most armenians because they never
really
you know the only thing we grew up with
learning about turkey is they the enemy
which is
i mean look in the newer generation we
don't really think like that anymore
i feel like that's kind of the case yeah
we don't feed hate anymore right what
i'm saying we actually blame
countries like azerbaijan and them for
raising their kids like we the enemy
for some reason so that country and they
literally have that like
matt clips was going around these last
few weeks of like school and
people teaching you know so in that
country they're literally indoctrinating
these kids to hate armenian people
we don't do that i like to say as much
anymore but
inside i mean that tension is always
there for sure that's great i mean think
about it if a million and a half people
were murdered like
a lot of our grandparents their entire
families got wiped out
you know what i'm saying but no one ever
paid the price so it's like a chip on
your [ __ ] shoulder this was 1918
right 1915
1915 okay 19 like 17 or 18. damn dude
yeah that's crazy i saw that uh there's
a movie that's coming out called a
promise with uh christian bale
yeah that came out a couple years ago
but it's coming out on netflix right now
okay i thought
it should be about it i think it's this
week it's on netflix now and that's
about the genocide that's about the
armenian genocide yep
that's the first time a big movie was
made about it too we went to the
premiere kim kardashian was there
i got my picture you got your kim
picture no i'm saying that she went
super viral
you post anything with kim you get mad
hits for no reason
do you feel like the kardashians uh are
there for the
because obviously their dad was armenian
um they are
okay they they they always speak about
it the armenian community loves them for
that you know what i'm saying because i
mean just
using your platform and obviously their
[ __ ] platform is so big
they talk about it a lot all of them do
you feel some sort of responsibility
being like someone who grew up in
amsterdam and obviously the hip-hop
community is such a
at least now i feel like just some it's
like a safe place for everybody i guess
you know like i'm bringing everybody
together to try to like
you know i guess as a leader of like
your community do you feel like any
pressure to try to like
bring bring people together or break
down any sort of stereotypes people
might have or
like anything like that so that's a good
that's a good question like i feel like
i always talked about these type of
issues because hip-hop being like the
voice of the voiceless the voice of the
people
just originally as a genre me coming in
from like a new
you know ethnicity into the game i had
to like represent or tell the story of
my people
yeah honestly i didn't i didn't know i
mean honestly i knew
based because i was like yo the you know
your your uh
brand your shirt our wounds are still
open yeah that i
i just that's that's how i figured out
what was going on and then
we have some some members of of our
staff at the station who are armenian
that kind of
kind of gave me up about the genocide
and i was like damn i had no [ __ ]
idea yeah that [ __ ] um
i could probably say like i did a lot of
damage because i did basically i just
did one song about it
i always say it's really a song about
crimes against humanity but specifically
i'm talking about the armenian and
genocide it's called opal wounds and
then we did these t-shirts
you know what i'm saying with the
hardwoods it's still open it just says
our ones are still open 1915.
and you know we just did that to like i
wore it in a video and we had a few
printed it wasn't like a thing we
thought of you know what i mean
but then everyone started asking about
those t-shirts and every time i was
wearing it
every single day someone would stop me
and say what does that mean
for some reason it's really like a dope
design and it catches people's attention
and um we realized like yo this is like
a
a tool to like create you know raise
awareness and educate people
kind of in a way never been done it's
kind of like a dope fresh new way using
hip hop and fashion
so then we started printing those shirts
and giving them to as many influences as
we could yeah man and like game was
definitely the first person i mean he
lived in glendale too so i was gonna say
gang used to live in glendale yeah so
he'd been around armenia so he
he knew the struggle and he knew so he
embraced it right away he posted it and
then he jumped on the remix of the song
you know
fire shout out the game but then after
that so many people you know we got
cardi
we got post we got met the man wearing
there is there any eggs we got
as far as what's going on in your
country right now is there any way
people can like
i i guess i don't know is there any sort
of way like people can help or
yeah for sure spread awareness i always
say there's like
two ways you can help obviously spread
awareness like we
we'd love for other you know races and
people
i never even heard of that other country
that's what's crazy right and everything
it must be very small it's a small
country mean armenia being
small i think azerbaijan is even smaller
right if i'm not mistaken yeah
so it's it's a super small country and
it's it sucks because you guys are from
the same part of the
like the main thing about armenians is
we originally christian right
um armenians are actually the first
christian nation in the whole world like
officially
adopted christianity and like the year
301
you know what i mean like the first
christian nation in the world everyone
surrounding it is like pretty extreme
muslim it's
iran it's turkey so it's always been
religion
history it's always been a religious
thing yeah religion is a [ __ ]
ain't it sure
that [ __ ] is crazy to think like that is
like
it's crazy that that's probably the
reason of all most wars and i think
i mean i think at the root of them
probably all of them
like every single war that's wild
there's religion wrapped up in there
somewhere
it's [ __ ]